[Music]
Blue Rock Sanji Selection 5-on-5
World Invitation Selection
The rules are the same as the second selection, and I will carve out the existence of a 5-point player. It's a
debut for the new Bachira. It's
amazing.
Standing as a person who fits within my image is a
choice that can be handled and evolved.  This only resonates with me. This
guy's new soccer super
egoistic dribbling style. The
image of the drumsticks and the
road that is linked to the edge of the outside.
My positioning that I can aim at. Show me here.
If it's coming from somewhere, I'll start making moves to outwit this guy.  It's
here
[Music]
Unprecedented movements and instantaneous science reactions against an amazing world-class opponent,
become fangs that reach the world
[Music]
I'll decide what's next